but really quick before we start this
episode down below in the description
you can subscribe to the brand new iced
coffee hour
clips channels we're also going to be
posting some fun behind the scenes and
exclusive content down there so make
sure
if you haven't done it already down
below in the description subscribe
hi everyone welcome back to the 56th
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
podcast my name is nsumaza and so far
channel has made sixty eight thousand
seven hundred eighteen dollars
and seventy four cents we did it wow
jack was that the best one yet
dare i say it i dare you i think that
was the best introduction we've ever had
on the ice coffee
thank you guys so much here's your phone
thank you thank you so much
yeah really thank you so much for
driving all the way to las vegas so we
could do this today
now for those that are not aware you
have a youtube channel where you tour
the most expensive luxury ultra high net
worth houses
in the planet pretty much you see the
best of the best
now you're touring like 100 million
dollar boats you're getting to see
what it's like to be ultra rich to have
hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars
and get an inside look into how these
people live and how they spend their
money
and your youtube channel is getting very
close to by the way a million
subscribers so we're gonna link your
channel down below in the description
because i gotta say your home tour
videos are absolutely incredible
it's like it's watching like a cinematic
movie of like this
75 million dollar house thank you thank
you man
we work really hard and uh yeah we're
very fortunate to be able to tour these
homes
how did you get into this um you
actually know the part of the story i
know the story but they don't know the
story uh i'll give a quick recap so two
and a half years ago
i moved to la i used to flip homes in
texas
prior to that i was a student at texas a
m i was an athlete
back then so i graduated there got into
flipping
kind of like investing in real estate
around 2015 2016 heavily
flipped about 30 40 homes back in texas
and after that i was like
you have money you know you always
wanted to move to la why don't you just
take the leap of faith and
just move there and initially i wasn't
sure what i wanted to do in la i was
like maybe i developed properties maybe
i learned the real estate market a
little bit so two and a half years ago i
moved to la
got my real estate license and got into
the business
and the way i grew the business was
really simple i actually took your
course real estate course
it's awesome and both courses by the way
both real estate and youtube
i mean link down below in the
description actually now that i think
uh just speaking out loud you had a huge
influence on how i kind of built my
business in general
and three months in going to brokers
open seeing the homes
and you know me coming from a
contracting background i was like
why nobody's talking about these homes
uh and we have mikey right around the
corner
i called mikey probably two to three
months being into real estate agent i
was like mikey
i don't i'm not making any money i don't
know much you know i don't know many
people here but
these brokers opens are amazing why
don't you move to la
you can sleep on my couch and on like
the side we'll start shooting some
videos
and i watched your youtube academy
i was like seems simple enough and we
just started shooting homes and here we
are
explain that more you didn't just start
shooting homes and then we're here
and then you woke up one morning a
million subscribers okay fair enough
so how did this happen we started
shooting and it sucked at the beginning
i mean it was like
we were getting like 100 to 200 views we
were basically touring brokers open
and remember wait was this with your
gopro or what
you were touring with the gopro i
remember watching your early videos when
we first you first reached out and we'll
talk about that and say because that's a
crazy story yeah
watching this video yeah it's just a
gopro just kind of walking around these
like five to ten million dollar houses
in beverly hills or bel air
that's really no commentary you see
people like getting out of your ways
you're walking around
the houses are packed you know why we
were using gopro number one obviously it
was easy to use number two we were so
small nobody knew us we were kind of
embarrassed almost what we were doing we
were like
let's just use a gopro let's just stay
low-key and me and mikey were just
touring these homes getting sound bites
i was talking about details here and
there and i think
maybe i could be wrong on this we made
like 12 to 15 videos
and we were at like 300 subscribers like
it was a grind like it wasn't moving we
weren't really getting any progress
and uh i remember at that time we
watched your academy probably twice
at that point i was like we gotta find a
way to meet graham
now i haven't told you this but yeah
i've emailed you before moving to la
i've emailed you probably two to three
weeks after moving to like
and uh i've never heard back which now i
truly
don't blame you the amount of emails and
dm's we get hundreds
hundreds per day it's in my impossible
it's impossible
to we we we will some we'll sort through
all the titles
but even like the time we miss emails so
so much so we got to work on that
now like yeah no hard feelings like i
totally get it and then uh
and then i saw this uh listing that hit
the market and you were either a
co-listing agent or you're a listing
agent on it
i told mikey about i was like mikey
graham listed a property
because at the time it was hard to find
you you weren't really fully into real
estate
this was like probably a little less
than two years ago
and then uh yeah this is just by the way
as i was phasing out yes
i was focusing more time on youtube and
a client called me from
youtube believe it or not okay saw my
youtube video and said
uh i forget how she reached out i think
she found one one of my other email
addresses reached out to me
saying that she had a five and a half
million dollar home in west hollywood
okay
and i was scaling back but this was like
right up the street from my office i
spoke with jason to make it
listing yeah it was a great listing um
right up the street from the office 500
million dollars
view of the entire city and jason said
listen don't worry about it if you're
not able to make a showing
i'll make this showing so uh so we're
able to make it work but that's that's
how i got the listing is from youtube
there you go that's amazing yeah um and
i remember seeing the listing i was like
mikey graham's
listing your property and then i saw the
brokers open i was like
grandma's gotta be there uh mikey was
like ah you know we
we reached out to him he never got back
i don't know maybe we shouldn't like
push this anymore further i was like i
don't want to hesitate this let's just
go
so we literally came to that open house
just to see you
and i remember really well because after
meeting you mikey was like you came in
really hot
like you're like hey guys welcome to my
listing i was like we're not here for
your listing we just came to meet you
like i almost came off too bold but uh
that was the time we met you and you
gave us like some really good advice
i remember so well i think i was editing
by the way in that open house i had my
computer open because it was a slow open
house
yeah because what happens in los angeles
is that when you list a house like that
the first weekend is packed all the
agents and people go and see the brand
new listing
after the first week it really settles
down so you really have that beginning
uh the momentum
i think you came in like the second or
third week i think possible
on a sunday it was a slow sunday i was
editing yeah
yeah uh and then like i remember one of
the first things i'm sure mikey
remembers it too
we were doing like vlog number eleven
twelve you're like no one cares no one
cares about the number he's like
title these videos was like wait wait
what like no one cares like
what do you mean like i couldn't even
comprehend what that meant
at the time we were so like i guess not
educated enough about youtube and
platform but
that's how we kind of met you for the
first time yeah and you had 300
subscribers back then
and from there your channel started to
grow and develop
and you started to get more bold with
touring some of these houses
when did you leave the gopro and start
going with like a nicer camera
i would say after meeting you kind of me
and mikey sitting on this thing for a
couple of months at that time
i think couple things started click and
i just kind of
started to look at the videos as like a
whole i'm like you know we're not clear
what we're doing no one knows who we are
so
let's make it simpler let's make it
about just one home right
start to finish and then from there
listening feedback of the viewers
kind of understanding why they comment
the way they comment
optimizing it and i feel like four to
five months later
me and mikey's gears were like shifting
in the right way
and then from there we're like let's use
a better camera let's use a better lens
let's be a little bit more careful on
how we walk these homes let's get a
little bit better listings
and one of our gopro videos it was like
this 49 million
home in bel air one morning i can't
remember the exact number but uh
me and mikey woke up we were like are
you seeing what's happening
we got like 10 000 views and then that
video just went viral
i had like i can't remember the numbers
but like it was a lot of use for the
time
so that was the first relief of
we can do this like it's possible and
from there we just
articulated our thoughts make better
videos brought in like sony cameras
brought in more help and the channel
just kind of grew did you ever
get any agents complaining about the
that gopro footage like you touring
their house without their permission
like
the belair house i would imagine the
listing agent eventually gets wind of
this
hey we see this video i didn't know you
were filming take the video down
every single one of those songs we
actually asked the agents we're like
we're shooting this
small gopro vlog are you okay with it
because no one knows that they're like
yeah sure whatever do whatever you want
and we're actually really good friends
now with the listing agent of that
property really
in fact he's also his name is marco
nagar okay he's with aaron
sure and aaron kerman is awesome by the
way yeah he's
nothing but aaron kerman is like one of
the los angeles best agents
yeah he's big without a doubt and uh
marco is the listing agent on a 110
million dollar ranch
that we shot recently so we're actually
really good friends with him now
that's so cool and then you reached out
to me again i think when you had what
was it like forty fifty thousand
something four fifty thousand
subscribers and we
met at a like a coffee shop got avocado
toast that's right and talked about
strategy to grow the channel and it's
incredible to see how it's grown from
there
and the properties that you're able to
get access to right now
are truly one of a kind so what's
something that when people see these
houses
and what's it like for you by the way to
walk through a house it's like 50
million dollars or 65 million of what
stands out
but first i want to thank our sponsor
ladder recently i've been looking to buy
a new home in las vegas so i can finally
move out of grams i'm just so tired of
graham bursting in my room and asking me
to smash the like button on all of his
videos
every time he posts ideally i'd love an
amazing view of the mountains so i can
really enjoy what life has to offer and
of course i would love for it to have a
decent sized garage and a pool that i
would actually heat
gram and most importantly a nice trophy
case for my biggest paper hands awards
and this absolutely awesome experience
of searching for my first ever home
serves as a reminder of how beautiful
life is and exactly why it should be
protected on that note it makes sense
why people get life insurance especially
term coverage which is surprisingly
affordable why not pay a little bit each
month to protect the ones that you love
ladder makes it impressively fast and
easy to get covered you just need a few
minutes a phone or a laptop to apply
ladder's smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved and there are no hidden
fees and you can cancel at any time and
since life insurance costs more as you
age
now is the perfect time to cross it off
your list so check out ladder today and
see if you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
so like at this point both myself and
the whole team mikey we're kind of
really trained we're almost like okay
we're going what do we talk about
um it's almost hard for me to be really
really impressed because i've seen so
many
good homes right but we're at a price
point now like every home we tour
is actually somewhat different you know
when you start touring homes at like 40
50 million dollars
you have to make them different that's
what people are looking to see you know
you cannot kind of
copy the formula that all the developers
are copying
um generally the things that i look for
are just like
scale proportions i'm really big in
sizes of rooms like
if you cannot get your proportions right
i feel like houses always sits
weird i always look at architectural
details how an architect designed the
home
how it takes advantage of the v
corridors how well the lot is utilized
as you know a lot of the homes in la are
hillside
so it's always kind of amazing to see
how they utilize these
properties and make the best out of them
and i you know we really look forward to
travel outside of california and outside
of the country
to really see different stuff yeah
what's been your favorite house like
what what features to use like shocks
you um
we haven't released this video yet but
uh a few days ago we shot this home in
hollywood hills
we were actually reached out by the
owner
because owner was a really good friend
of another friend of ours was a
developer
and he was like you have to let these
guys shoot your home
and it's this beautiful modern
architecture right on uh
collingwood and it's a stunning property
54 million 950 000 it has these bifold
shades that automatically retracts to
the roof
so you can put these metal shades up
front it's like sits on a promotory
the whole house was just sick like
i i'm so impressed with that house
without a doubt that's my favorite home
here in l.a
and uh hopefully that episode will be
out in like
by like mid-june what's the most unusual
feature you've seen in the house
like this one weird thing that we saw i
was like ah that's interesting we saw
this guy install a black toilet that
lifts up like a lambo door
and he had black uh toilet paper i was
like this black
toilet paper i thought it was cool i was
like that's interesting wow it seems
impractical
it does to have black toilet paper yeah
but i mean like
talking about attention to detail i was
like good for you like that's kind of
awesome
um a lot of these drop down tvs hidden
features
honestly that house again we haven't
released that video but it has these
like bifold shades
like metal shapes that sits outside of
the home it's like a
railing that protects the home and with
a click of a button
it bifolds and like stacks to the roof
and sits like a cantilever
actually this guy was like obsessed with
uh
utilizing the outdoor spaces he put
space heaters everywhere
that comes down from cantilevers and
motorizes down so it's like sits two
feet above you
so i thought that house probably has
some of the coolest features
going and seeing all these 40 50 million
dollar homes is that something that you
would want to achieve at some point in
your life and if so
which home that you've toured is the
home that you would prefer to live in
like your favorite home for you to to
live in
so i have a confession to make uh i used
to be
really really inspired by these homes in
terms of like i would love to live in
one of these
and don't get me wrong they're amazing
but they're so big
they're so expensive and when you think
about the running costs utilities
and like the overall liability of
owning a home like that and kind of the
stress it causes on you i'm not gonna
lie
i'm almost a little bit turned off on
having these kind of luxuries like
i would almost want like a two-bedroom
house in hollywood hills that's simple
that gets a good view and has the open
living room that'd be good enough for me
it's something about these really mega
mansions it's just
it's kind of overwhelming it's a lot of
people don't know this like it's amazing
to see them it's amazing to hang out at
them and all that
would i want to have him as my home and
spend like i don't know like a million
bucks a year on property taxes
it's a bit insane yeah so which home
that you've toured is the home that
you'd prefer to live in
it would be this this again same home or
for snow you know for snow that
home with three different uh candles
yeah
without a doubt those are my two
favorite homes in la one of them is
viewpoint
uh i think it's 28 million dollars now
it's one of our popular videos
has like two and a half million views i
believe uh that home and the last one we
toured
those would be my two favorite what are
the owners like
of these properties can you talk about
like
because i feel like once because to buy
a house it's
just 50 million most likely they're
worth anywhere between i would say 100
billion on the very low end
to probably realistically about 500
million to a billion
uh what are they like so it's
interesting
every single one of them like it's like
different personalities
some a lot of times we deal with
developers they're kind of like it's an
investment for them it's a risk
um every once in a while we meet these
owners with such unique backgrounds like
i won't give the exact names but one of
them was a film producer
and he's also an investment banker the
other one is like
uh uh which we are gonna release a video
he's a developer from russia
and he used to be in a bachelor's like
of russia
he's really famous in actually ukraine
and russia and he develops these like
sick homes and hidden hills hollywood
hills
he's a totally different personality um
like sometimes we tour these development
companies listings that are like big
firms like with like
50 other investment it really depends a
lot of the times we either deal with
the realtors or the developers because a
lot of the homes we try to avoid touring
homes that
has personal furniture just for
liability
and we don't want to expose their like
personal life so a lot of the homes we
tour are like staged all polished up
so we end up dealing with for the most
part with developers
have you ever filmed and like released a
video and then
after the fact you know either let's say
like the the buyer or something wanted
you to take the
the video down and you had to remove it
happened couple times
and we tried to honor it and not from a
point of view of
uh like we shot it beyond that content
it's more so
i mean i don't want to have the feeling
of like
knowing that someone is living in that
house and they're uncomfortable to have
the video up
it's just like i don't want to put that
kind of karma out on our channel and
just it's personally not worth it for us
we just kind of like
fine like that's why like we try to not
showcase the home from exterior that
much
on the street level and i kind of keep
it private because we want to keep these
episodes they're super hard to make
we spend so much time i mean it's
mind-boggling the amount of hours
we put into making one video so we try
to take keep him but
if we have to take him out we take him
out yeah there's one video that jack and
i did
a while back where we traveled to go and
tour this house
and shortly afterwards she sold the
house and wanted the video down
and we know that by taking a video down
it affects the algorithm and by removing
even
even if it doesn't get any views by
removing an old video it tends to drop
the entire channel
and my concern was that by removing this
video this could potentially cost us
tens of thousands of dollars
uh potentially even a hundred or two
hundred thousand dollars over the course
of you know who knows how long
if this drops our views from removing a
video so we ultimately were able to work
it out where we kept the video up
but that became a major concern for us
moving forward with house tours
is that if someone buys the house they
don't want anything on there on the mls
especially in that price point
it becomes a tough one it is a tough one
it's one of those challenges um
we deal on a daily basis
and i just kind of look at it as like
it's another difficulty that most people
would struggle to deal with
and we'll figure out a way to do it what
was the most expensive home you've been
through
110 million dollars santa barbara 3600
acre ranch with like
three mega homes plus like 10 other like
uh staff homes it took us three days to
shoot this property
yeah we almost died trying to make this
video happen like it's a 49 minute video
and we're a little bit reserved and i
like that about us like meaning we don't
really expose what we do that much we
kind of stay quiet and we just focus on
our work
that video almost killed us like the
amount of work that we put in
shooting we were shooting like 12 hours
a day for three days
we had a car from beverly hills come in
they were so separated from each other
so we all had to work remotely
um it was a huge challenge and
we made it happen it has like 1.1
million views i believe in like 30 days
who reached out to you for that was it
the owner agent or
developer agent reached out to us to
kind of discuss the idea
and you can imagine when someone gives
you 110 million dollar
asset it's a big responsibility
and there were so many things to talk
about that house i was almost exhausted
trying to
remember everything about it because
these owners are counting on me to make
sure
we highlight these features you know
there's a lot of pride in uh owner you
know pride and ownership goes into 110
million dollar home
so that was just a lot of pressure but
the agent reached out
and we kind of put this plan together
we're like this is how we can shoot it
because it's such an overwhelming
property to show in person
each showing is like six hours so we
were like how can we make this a video
where someone can watch us for 40
minutes and really understand
fundamentals about the property and if
they're interested they can go see it
we almost wanted to create like a
virtual link for the real estate agent
so even with so much plan it still ended
up being like 50 minutes yeah it was
insane it's funny you mentioned a six
hour showing
there was what was that the property i'm
blanking on the name
it was on the market 250 million uh
like bruce mccuskey yes yeah yeah uh
he was explaining because he gave a tour
to all of us at the oppenheim group
and explained that every showing that
they do was like 15 000
just to bring in a buyer because every
time you go in
there are perfectly fresh flowers
throughout the entire thing um so
everything and
they don't keep them overnight like this
is just for the time the buyer walks
through it's like 15 grand and the agent
by the way was paying for this
so and this this was a request of the
owner so every showing yeah
they had they had to have fresh flowers
they also had to have i think
the staff there to meet the prospective
buyers so they could meet each other
face to face
uh they also had i think it was food and
they also had i think of
ace of spades champagne so by the time
you walked up
you were given like the full treatment
uh and you were able to meet the staff
so just imagine like uh and oh and he
was even explaining by the way
that they've had showings where they've
been fully ready and the buyer cancels
oh my god imagine that just the buyer
like last minute
sorry i can't make it honestly 18 grand
is gone i i totally get it and
it's actually the right call because
anybody's spending money at that level
logic is off the table it's it's fully
riding on emotion like you go in there
you smell the house
you get the feeling you're like this is
how i want to feel i want to own this
place
and whoever buys a 100 200 million home
it's an emotional purchase i mean it's a
tough one to justify just like hey i can
afford it
and i would like to have this house so
i'm just going to have it you know so
i think it's the right call and every
showing is so important
pretty much anybody that you get through
the door at that price point they're
billionaires
yeah so yeah that to me was probably the
craziest house i've ever seen
not so much for for the the price point
but just
because when you hear the story behind
every little bit
every item every corner has a house
crazy behind it
uh like it was the uh the the powder
room
sink was worth 400 000
for just the sink in the guest bathroom
because of like it came from a castle
yeah um every piece of art was like hand
curated
they had onyx on the outside of the
house that was
it's like you nobody puts onyx as as an
exterior wall of the house so expensive
yeah everything even the the movie
theater like the the equipment alone was
like a million dollars just for the
equipment
it was it was just insane i mean i feel
like
that home and the home next door to that
in bel air those were really
experimental
projects for los angeles even selling it
at 88 million dollars
i think broke like a new layer of like
what's possible
i do my only two points on those two
homes are
i think at that price point people look
for land and they seem to lack a little
bit of land i think
especially bruce's home was like well
executed in terms of like what kind of
unique things you get in a home like
that i just felt like they were not big
enough in terms of properties
and i don't care how cool your home is
people at that price point look for land
look for like they go in and they're
like this is my backyard i can have
thousand people here
and because they don't see these homes
as just homes they're like assets where
you like
leverage off to like get the right
people through the door that kind of
stuff what i've noticed though is that
those buyers are sometimes the most like
stringent when it comes to budgets and
they'll
basically just in their mind walk
through the home be like okay that's a
million that's a million
and they'll come up with the cost of
like how much it'll be to build that
house
yeah plus the cost of the land plus the
cost of carrying cost plus the cost of
the guys time they'll make an offer
based on the profit they think the owner
should be making i've seen that that's
true
so much they're like hey listen you're
in this house i'm just gonna
guess 60 million dollars you're in this
uh
okay your time is worth you know six
million a year we're gonna offer this
and that you know regardless of what the
asking price is that's what i've seen
most of the time
and i don't blame them i mean every
house we go back it's not that hard for
me to like
roughly estimate how much they put in
you know even if it's a hillside where
engineering and foundation and chaos can
be quite variable
it's not that difficult to calculate so
a lot of these people at that price
point they have resources where people
they can literally hire two engineers
and a good contractor to be like
give me a rough estimate how much these
people are in yeah and they can just sit
down
they can see the purchase price for the
land the time that they hold the
property
i would like to think if i do a one to
two day research i can probably
guess the cost of a property to a 95
accuracy yeah so
yeah i remember too uh jason oppenheim
uh jason oppenheim had the listing i
think it was 44 million dollars in
hollywood
yeah and the guy it's on hillside right
yeah yeah and the guys spent i think it
was just over a million dollars removing
the few power poles
in front of the view welcome to at like
i think it was 100 or 150 000
each to put the power pole underground
yeah in the hollywood hill so that way
when you look at your view you don't see
a wire
going across the city that could be a 5
million dollar swing yeah on the sales
price
having the pull versus not pulled i
can't tell you how many homes i've sold
in the three to six million dollar price
point
where the reason they didn't buy the
house was because
right by the bedroom on that second
floor the third floor
this buzzing of this big power pole and
they feel like
i don't want to be next to that what if
it gives off some sort of radiation
what people just hate it yeah i know but
it doesn't make sense you can't remove
it at that price because you never get
your money back
but above like 30 million bucks you got
it people demand a higher caliber of
home
without a doubt i totally agree you know
these luxury homes
they're they're a little overwhelming
sometimes but
and it's it's almost interesting to me
to see that like most of them sits empty
it's kind of because people that can
afford these homes
they're so like wealthy that they
probably are running big businesses
they can't even enjoy it uh we toured
one home owner was like
he owned the home for two years i'm this
is not a joke he's like i'm never
sweating
in that pool me and mikey were like
looking each other i was like
what he's never swimming in the pool
yeah that reminds me of someone
actually yeah i relate to the guy yeah
yeah
so that's not a smaller scale
yep geez yeah we've
i i am always surprised at the level of
um
just the wealth that's out there that
yeah these these houses just about empty
they don't care uh there's there's
another property that we had a listing
of
this is many years ago in beverly hills
i think that the property was anywhere
from like 50 it was over 15 million
and uh the owner bought it intended to
move in
and just decided he wanted something
else instead
that was it nothing wrong with the house
just bought the house you know what
we actually saw something a little bit
nicer bought the other house instead now
think the market went up
so we ended up selling it for a profit
so he bought this house
made money on it but to buy a house like
like that expensive and be
oh this other house i'm gonna buy that
instead
just doesn't care we toured another
house and then like owners pro i mean
they were technically living in it
they're like yeah their kid is going to
uh ucla so they bought this house it's
like a 20 million dollar
belair yes what you know so that's the
world we live in yeah there was uh
somebody i met at uh at a car meet who
was
i think he was a little bit younger than
me but his family bought
it must have been a 20 to a 40 million
dollar house in bel air
right by ucla because he was going to
ucla and that was it that was the only
and and their their uh logic behind it
was
well we'll be able to sell it for more
money because
it's a it's like a prime property i
actually i don't know if i could say
i think i should be able to say it was
one of like the walt disney estates
there's some sort of disney estate that
was there that they that they purchased
in holby hills but it has underground
tunnels by the way
that's crazy they connect to like an
adjacent property it was wild
we recently toured the godfather estate
the oh yeah beverly hills
yeah 90 million dollars that was a
pretty crazy one uh like they had a
nightclub
where they took hugh hefner's old
nightclubs like
furnishings and all that so they
replicated the club after it was closed
and brought all the furnishings to this
home so they have a nightclub that looks
like exact i think it was called touch
uh it was
hugh hefner's uh beverly hills nightclub
so that was really interesting
wow what do you think of the one
um it's really big now let's explain
this
this is the most expensive property in
is it in the world it's the world no
it's not in the world
i've i've seen the the antelia
listen but that's like a commercial
apartment building
it's a dumpling house it's a it's an
apartment building that you're buying a
skyscraper it's a home
that's a skyscraper it's a skyscraper
what do you think do you think it's a
home is that a house you know the one
time
yeah i know i know i mean unfortunately
i would say it's technically a home i
mean he's crazy enough to build it the
way he did
yeah i i get it i feel like that's
cheating
that's like you know i'm buying like a
big walmart oh
once you're building a house so big
wouldn't it make sense we were touring
this
uh penthouse in new york and during the
uh
when we were shooting it listing agents
were showing it to someone else
someone's representative they're like
yeah they're interested in buying
the top two floors in the bottom two
floors and doing like a five-story
penthouse each one of these penthouses
were like 50 million bucks
like are they just casually talking
about dumping 200 million dollars just
so they can have like top five floors
people do that stuff so i'm actually not
that surprised about that home
i mean people are crazy okay so we'll
call it a home
yeah fine fine he looks so happy of
course he looks happy
but okay so we'll call it it's it's the
second
one of the most what are your thoughts
on that um i mean
i think without a doubt the land that it
sits on has got to be one of the best
pieces of property
in the you know in los angeles if not in
the country
describe what makes it well it's this
really high promontory but
you know a lot of times promontories are
nice but if they're
set back and they're low a lot of people
look into it so i don't like that
it sits high enough and kind of pulled
back in bel air that is somewhat private
considering the elevation
so i like that about it number two um
it's just like he owns the whole hilltop
it's not just like he owns the edge of
it right like
you just go to the elevation it's that
property and that's it
uh in terms of architecture i mean it's
mclean it's a good home
mclean is an amazing architect you know
he does so many projects
in la where i would compliment on is
i mean it's so big you know i'm really
trying to understand who would be the
end user
and why it would make sense for them to
have that much square footage
uh i'll be lying if i say i'm educated
enough to understand and comprehend that
um we actually been in that property
about two two and a half months ago me
and mikey went there to check it out
uh we went uh we met one of the project
managers
and to our site at the time they were
about 90 percent done
uh it wasn't fully finished already i
mean it's a good home it's
it's a different take it's kind of like
that bruce mccoskey home like
it's a bold approach and he sold it you
know granted he started with 250 million
it ended up selling for 88. what would
happen with this
i don't know you know you saw the niles
video he has some bold
perspective on that house maybe they
would do something like that i don't
know it's it's a
it's a tough one for me to make a
comment yeah so they're asking 500
million
for the record wait i thought it was
250. now they're like i
didn't they go down to like 380 maybe
maybe 380. so they started like 500
million dollars
250 was the other house that we were
talking about the bruce mikowski house
with the
400 000 it's on billy road it's 400
500 million for this house it started
500 million yeah
lowered now uh they're having a memorial
day sale
just we know what we should do a
memorial day sale on the on the youtube
creator academy 200
off and the mentorship group okay
okay perfect you know what okay how
about this
well well jack and i will come up with a
discount on the mentorship group
and the youtube creator academy the
youtube creator academy 200
off i'll testify for that it works but
okay so anyway so it's reduced
to 380 and what do you what do you think
it's gonna sell for i mean you've seen
probably more
50 plus million dollar houses than
almost
anybody i would know that's such a tough
question to answer i
would say maybe somewhere around 1500 to
1800 a square foot
that would bring it to 160 to like 210
to 20-ish maybe
and that's just a basic uh
appraisal of new construction pricing
right the only issue is
this house has 110 000 square feet of
interior square footage so that's
a lot but it's one of a kind no one will
ever be able to recreate it
i mean there's like a whole story on
like how he pulled the permit on that
property where
it was almost like overlooked by
accident so like he got
approved by this mega home that no one
can ever build like
you can never recreate a home that size
and um
yeah it's it's going to be interesting
to see what's going to happen little
yes side tangent for that when i first
started selling real estate this is
beverly hills 2008
they had just passed what's called a
mansionization
ordinance just passed it and before this
you were you were you were given these
like five to six thousand square foot
lots
where you were able to build a 4 500
square foot house
insane yeah so basically imagine the
entire lot
is a huge mansion with
a backyard like the size of like a
little strip
yeah little strip as a backyard they
beverly hills did not like
that all of these hats were huge huge
developers were maxing it out so they
passed a mansionization ordinance that
says
now you could only build it was like
sixty percent
it was like sixty percent plus fifteen
hundred square feet it was or
something like that forty percent plus
fifteen hundred square feet of whatever
the lot size is
and that was the selling point was that
this is pre-manchinization
you're getting a bigger house you can't
build this anymore yeah
and so far uh they've only gotten more
strict they're scaling back on what you
could build
less square footage so yeah so that's a
good point there that you can't build
that anymore
and i don't know what kind of commercial
applications uh they could have but
i can't imagine anything up there like a
residential area well
i can't see maybe an embassy for uae i
don't know
i'm just like thinking you know just
wild thoughts yeah
what would like who would have to be the
buyer of a home like that
i mean what would the net worth of that
person have to be my gut will tell me
without a doubt it's going to be a
foreigner
and it's going to be maybe someone from
middle east someone from asia
because it's an easy asset to park a lot
of money on
so like you can literally put 200
million dollars in ground
in another country where they would have
to go through different jurisdictions to
be able to touch that asset
a lot of these people like to spread out
their wealth so they could literally be
like we can just dump 200 million there
it sits it's a new year they wouldn't
even live there i doubt it they
don't have the staff this would be there
like they would go in for three days and
they wouldn't
be not there for like another six months
kind of yeah i've seen so
yeah i've seen so many houses like that
uh especially from
especially from asia they want to bring
money to the united states and park it
anywhere they can
and in 2009 2009 and 10
they were buying up the majority of
beverly hills every single property
that would come on the market that that
uh either
either myself or someone in my team
would list would get an offer
automatically
just sight unseen it was a low offer so
imagine if we list a place for five
they'll say we'll pay 3.8 right now cash
sign on c no contingencies sign the deal
it's done we'll wire the money the next
day
they just didn't care but they lowball
everything most of the time they didn't
get taken seriously but
they're doing this enough so that it's a
numbers game like they they make 20
offers
they'll get one um and there's a listing
oh geez we had a listing on
uh don uh i think with don hill drive
beverly hills
and i think the listing at the time was
like 10 million bucks they offered like
six five or something like that and uh i
couldn't believe it i was like just
start on scene but yeah but oh and then
what's even crazier
is that they would have these home tours
they would all go together as a group of
investors like 15 to 20
and rent a like a bus and then go from
property to property to property
property lining up like 30 to 40 homes
over a weekend
and they would all be sitting there
writing offers on on houses
they'd all as a crazy group as an
investment to let the house
sit yep and they would pretty much write
an offer on everything just at a price
for them where there's enough upside but
i guaran whatever they bought
uh back then has probably doubled their
trip they probably made money on it oh
yeah
probably double or tripled and if
someone decides to buy this like the one
they lose all privacy right because like
there's no way that you can
go undiscovered if you're buying a
property yes you can
so it's buying a property i think it's
you you buy it within like
uh it's called a blind trust so you're
there's a very complicated way of doing
this where you buy it
in an llc held by a trust
held by another trust with some like
beneficiary being
a lawyer whose offices is you know in
new york
that's what i saw yeah like anytime like
celebrity doesn't want to show that they
own the home it's somehow their lawyer's
name on the on like the online
that's what they're going to do probably
for this property that's what i've seen
done
uh because we've represented a few
celebrities that do exactly that
the llc blind child everyone signs ndas
usually it slips usually someone else
what ends up happening is that
the some of these people are followed
around and so if they see a moving truck
um like i'm i won't mention who it is
but this one actress
that i represented she was moving can
you say we'll bleep it out
oh okay yeah but she was moving but they
had the paparazzi see the moving truck
oh and they followed the moving truck to
the new house
how would they know it was that actress
because they knew where she lived
from neighbors yeah dude it's tough to
be celebrated and then here's the other
thing too is they'll get
mail records you can't have anything in
your name
that gets sent to the property like you
think oh let me know why that's illegal
to
to go through someone's money they they
have ins they have ends they know
if if you even sign up for a magazine
to go to the property with your name on
it a hundred percent
that name gets sold and leaked you can't
have anything i don't
realize this but yeah utilities that's
not in your name
cable not your name nothing is in your
name
it's all done through a lawyer
everything yeah yeah and even
and then even like you do everything
perfectly but then you know the neighbor
and the neighbor somehow tells somebody
you tell somebody and they trace it back
to you
it's over so yeah for that level of
privacy would be really tough
honestly yeah it's tough and la's not a
cheap place even a lot of celebrities
struggle to get that privacy yeah
because it's just expensive yeah and
think of it too let's say that this
house sells
all it takes is for a few people to park
outside of the house and just sit there
with cameras
yeah guaranteed they'd be able to get a
shot even if you're driving in and like
you know a completely blacked out
escalator
you'd be able to get a picture from the
front or sometimes people are like
with drones and like you should call the
police but like
by then it's too late all it takes is
one telescope
figure out who it is track it i agree
yeah there's no way of
true privacy like that yeah it's nuts
it's tough
everybody wants privacy but it's tough
to get it in la unless you have a lot of
money
yeah wow so what do you think the land
is worth of the one
because he bought it for i think a blow
up right what was it like 18 million
dollars
back in 2011. i mean i can easily see
trading like you see what i would have
done is
it's four acres i would have built a 30
000 square foot spec home
ask 120 million and it would have sold
yeah that's what i would have done
yeah i mean that's like my automatic
initial gut instinct i would have had a
sick backyard
just 150 feet pool just all out with the
outdoor space
and let the outdoor space be the focus
and priority rather than like this mega
home
and he would have he would have easily
gone hundred twenty on like a six thirty
forty
thousand square foot but the issue that
i see with that is that
the reason why developers build so much
square footage as you know is it
it's cheap to add that extra few square
feet
but once you're building it adding in
that little extra bit isn't it
yes high roi yes and no like at a scale
of like between 25 000 to 30 000
sure but when you go 100 plus
like the mass or weight that you hold
there now your case
i feel like his oversize probably add up
so much in the engineering now you have
to run
multiple breakers like it's not just
like you have a little bit more
it's like then you got to design the
whole thing then you have flaws
you have now a huge roof that you want
to make sure it doesn't leak and it's
flat i don't know i don't know if it's
worth it to me like i said
for the price he's gone i think it's a
bargain i can see that land trading for
like 50 million
easy right now 60 million event just a
land alone
i would have just put a 35 000 square
foot modern
you know something timeless get it
beautifully designed ask hundred fifty
hundred forty
you know would do well as uh just a very
sustainable house up there
like honestly if he could have designed
something that was completely off the
grid off the grid or
you know it's not like off the grid but
it could be if you wanted to be off the
grid something
something eco-friendly with a whole
bunch of trees
like like really create like a forest
because that doesn't exist something
unique almost
yeah yeah speaking of which the one
house that i that i saw online recently
is ashton kutcher's house have you seen
it yeah it's pretty cool we got to throw
up pictures of this
yeah it is in my opinion one of my
favorite properties
ever that i've ever seen it's it's built
as a barn
it's like a modern barn with privacy
surrounded by greenery and nature and
it's open
but but it's but it's contemporary like
it feels like something that is built
today
but it has that charm of something
that's like a hundred years old i've
never seen anything like it
i saw it too i was like oh maybe we get
lucky we get a chance to tour it but uh
no it's a pretty nice home right not a
doubt so what do you think the
developers cost is
on the one you i want you to estimate
um gosh
because you know what i'm gonna write
down a number yeah yeah and then we'll
compare
yeah so then i'm gonna guess i'll guess
too i'll go
we can't say any numbers here so i have
a number and i have it on my phone
okay who wants to jack i want you to go
first jack all right 175 million dollars
is how much i think it cost
to build the one and we're talking about
just cost
cost of the property not the land just
to build not the land as well i'm just
saying all in like developers cost
no no we're just going to land is around
18 million so you can come up with like
your exact number on how much do you
think it could
be 157 then okay 100 wait 157 is your
cost to build the house
that's what we're talking about wait the
house but what about like the trees and
the grass and all that well that's
included
that's like that's improvements yeah
yeah not the land
okay so just that okay 157 million
okay 55 155 no one
just sorry sir just 55 million oh you
think it's 55 million
without a doubt at lowest he's at
900 a square foot which would be about
95 million i say this because it took
over eight years
seven eight years for this property to
be built up just the carrying costs
and being able to maintain the property
up there it should build up
oh we're not talking about carrying cost
so i did 600
square foot no 600 square foot because
of how
much square footage there was i'll be
really curious if this information won
the leaks i would say without a doubt
minimum 900 dollars a square foot
95 million i can see it as high as
1300 a foot 140 million yeah you've seen
it
i've i've only seen the video of it you
know why because it's just like not even
like the finishes thing but
when skill changes he has these huge
marble walls
those are full slabs i have a feeling
they got big cranes up there
the trees he got those are not just like
brought by trucks
you know like you add these little
things up that movie theater that's not
a just a movie theater he must have
spent
ridiculous amount of money and he has
custom stuff in there
so i would like a movie theater alone
would be five six million dollars
exactly minimum he has that like second
floor roof
that means the whole thing is probably
still cantilever and
i don't know my gut tells me lowest 90
million highest 140
for the construction cost not the land
wow
that's insane so you don't think he's
gonna make much money on this
considering how much time he's put in
and how much he's spent because right
now he's in foreclosure and he's behind
he's behind us there has been that
article and i think like
he actually talked about it in the video
that producer michael did that uh
he's behind his payments i honestly
don't know and it's one of those things
that uh
because i'm not involved in it i don't
want to make that many comments on it i
would like just to
kind of stay out of it but uh it's just
an interesting bold take
you know that's kind of all i have how
do you finance a home like that
like to be able to borrow that much
money investors
and partially bank but not all of it
that's such a spec home that
i have a feeling bank wouldn't finance
at all i'd be like we'll throw in some
what rate do you think bank did finance
it for him
because he has a track record of
building these these houses
i thought a bank did i thought a bank is
involved i don't know if they
financed at all yeah
i have a feeling big chunk of it is
probably the bank um
but again who knows yeah you know what's
funny did that saying where it's like if
you owe the bank a million dollars
that's your problem
if you had the bank 100 million dollars
that's their problem
yeah it's true yeah yeah and now and now
niles the one who could call the shots
because if if that property gets
foreclosed it's losing 30
value like you can't foreclose on that
house yeah
you you have to work with him you don't
have a choice like you literally have to
hire a few people to manage that
foreclosure as an
asset because it's so expensive you're
like imagine trying to figure out the
electronics on that thing yeah
out of the blue it's it's crazy yeah
so we should probably swing the
conversation into like youtube success
okay so what do you think set you apart
from other
you know youtubers that tour these homes
why did your
channel blow up so quickly instead of
theirs
so that's a the way i mean there's so
many things to talk about that but
number one thing i would say is
we really try to showcase these homes in
a way that uh
that honors the property right like i
want to make sure owners are happy with
the end product
developers are proud and we you know i
felt like a lot of these homes that are
20 30 million in la
people are like these are just
ridiculously priced i'm like well nobody
knows how to talk about them and they're
not easy to develop they take years to
develop
permitting process is insane and some of
these details look so sim
simple but they're not easy to execute
on so
we just try to cover those things and i
think people appreciate understanding
why they are 30 million dollars right
and we explain it from a point of view
of like not being a realtor like it's
like
hey this is how it works and let me
explain it to you so
i don't like salesmanship i'm not a good
salesman
i don't think when i was a realtor i was
probably not the best realtor
from a point of view like i wasn't pushy
i was like you you weren't pushy either
you were like hey
work with me if you like me i'm kind of
that way and i think people like that
so and on top of that the whole
production side of things
we really take pride in what we do and i
think we put mind-boggling amounts of
hours in the videos
how many hours would you say each video
takes
you're talking about like the
post-production side of the security
hours
start defending before even like getting
the house yeah
from the time i see it and somehow i get
introduced to the owner
or like i re i reach out or they reach
out to me
meeting preparing for the house planning
shooting
editing it's got to be 120 to 140 hours
perfect easily man hours easily and
that's like between me
mikey and the rest of the team like
easily
one video and we do it every week that's
that's honestly the most challenging
part of it
keeping the quality and raising the bar
while maintaining this
with the type of homes in the type of
style we shoot
them this is the one of the most
difficult puzzles
we've ever had to put like it i lose my
hair over this every day
and you were bringing up all of your
expenses like like your equipment yeah
what are your expenses on this
i mean for the production gear you gotta
be probably around hundred thousand if
not more
no yeah two imacs wow hard drive after
hard drive
small hard drives multiple sony cameras
audio equipment shotgun mics
multiple drones big drone uh we have
inspire
memory cards lenses i believe our
expensive drone
the lens set alone on that the lens kit
with like multiple lenses
is like 12 grand wow
and you know what i guarantee people are
at home watching your video think
that's easy look at that two cameras
walk through for an hour
oh yeah gets to see cool houses all day
it's
a it's a big challenge that we put
together you know where it becomes
really difficult
is with your videos or what you guys do
you guys can control the product
like the video core itself with us the
product that we make the video off of is
someone else's
that's such a delicate balance to manage
and
be able to make the content around their
product
where they're on board and you still
manage to pull off your vision on it
you know we don't get the freedom that
you guys have where you can take the
conversation wherever you want
you can make fun of it or not we can't
so it's a really difficult balance that
we deal with every day so how is it for
you to see
all of our equipment over here in our
setup with our lights and our towel
light diffusers what do you think of all
of this
do you think it would be in our best
interest to upgrade some of our
equipment
um i feel like jack is really putting
graham on a tough spot here
so here's where i'm at tell me a way
to improve the content or whatever we're
doing
better as long as i can get behind the
cost of it
like i will spend whatever money it
takes like i literally were talking to
mikey i was like
you have a good idea that you can
express to me and justify it
i'll invest half a million dollars
tomorrow without a blink of an eye
i'll empty my stock account and i'll
just invest it it's all about to me
business i take my emotions out it's
about is this worth the investment and
it's not just from a money point of view
i look at things as a as um for example
we buy an equipment
how much time do we have to spend on
this equipment what kind of returns
we're gonna get
how are footage is gonna improve is that
worth it
is that's gonna make our videos better
where we get more views or like
our overall quality is gonna go up if
you can justify it to me i will spend
any money needed
i'm kind of humbled i i take bold risks
i feel like there's diminishing returns
like to go from no camera to an iphone
boom big big upside there you go to go
from an iphone to a dslr
boom big upside to go from a dslr to 4k
okay maybe five percent to go from 4k to
then getting all these
fancy lights maybe another few percent
better audio you know or or to go from
like a shotgun to a
wireless mic yeah that's going to do
well but to go from the wireless bike to
a road
it starts tapering off in terms of what
you could accomplish and i think
i at least feel for my videos the real
magic is in the planning and the story
behind what i'm talking about and less
and like
fancy equipment and i i love
the homegrown nature of the channel i
started in my garage making videos
and i'm still kind of in a garage making
videos that that isn't changing
i like the fact that it's like it's me
doing it myself
and it's not like it's a big corporation
or a production team
so i like the fact that i'm using the
same camera as i did four years ago that
i bought
used on ebay because it was cheaper i
i feel like that just that that's the
organic
uh nature of the content and honestly
for you and
what you guys are trying to do i get it
for us
without a doubt we want to become the
most versatile
and the best team in the world like
i'll say this out loud in the world to
shoot these homes
globally and some of these other
expensive assets
so for us to get to that level if
there's a way we can improve the content
by
0.01 you have my attention let's talk
that's how i see it so i'm brutal when
it comes to this stuff
where i kind of hold it back is i want
it to be
like when whatever improvement we're
doing it needs to be practically applied
or we need to have a plan in place
to integrate just because a hundred
thousand dollar camera is better
yeah but do we know how to shoot with
that do we know how to process that
if you don't that to me is actually not
a good investment
yeah but you tell me how we can
integrate that into our operation
i'll go by tomorrow i was about to say
oh
do you ever worry about running out of
houses or like not having one lined up
for a week like how
far in advance do you film music right
now we do four to five weeks ahead
that's smart yeah that's that's the only
way we can deal with the fluctuations
because last minute it rains
last minute owner changes their mind
it's too much
i wish people can understand the amount
of abuse and like stress we go through
trying to produce these videos and we're
we have a laid back personality me and
mikey
um where we're like kind of easy about
this stuff but uh it's crazy
of a logistics that we deal on the back
end putting this together but we
shouldn't advance
i would like to say our second channel
we probably have
always four to five videos in inventory
we may not be able to edit them right
away but we have them we do the same
thing
on ours we always like to be a week
ahead on the podcast i'm always
one to two videos ahead at any given
point on the the main channel
we're always about one to three videos
ahead on the second channel
yeah um and the podcast is week by week
gotcha so that that's the most
up-to-date stuff
nice well yeah i mean yeah
to us in order to run it at the level we
want we need to be ahead
uh that's just the bottom line some of
these agents reach out to me they're
like
can we have it by next week i'm like
yeah and that's just the price like
you want to be ahead with us you need to
let me know two months in advance and
i'll schedule you accordingly
and i'll book you a slot what if they
paid you what if they said
hey we want this video to be up next
week we'll give you thirty thousand
dollars
can you can you make it will you we i
could probably
talk the other owners and like push it i
i may be able to make it work
obviously any any pay helps to up our
operation and all that
um but i try to like i don't sell the
services
meaning if you don't like it i don't
care how much they pay us
i won't say the name but a big builder
reached out to us
and i wasn't feeling their property they
offered us a really good money i was
like no chance can you tell us how much
like you don't have to say what it is
but twelve thousand dollars and i was
like no chance
for one video yeah okay yeah were they
trying to sell the listing or what was
i don't like their product and yeah i i
like
i can't go there and be like their
houses are great yeah no chance
but from their perspective did they hope
that you would be like this is an
amazing house here's how cool it is it
would get all these people
they wanted us to they wanted us to do
exactly what we do but i genuinely
wasn't stoked about the house
like i turn down like 30 homes a week if
i don't like feel like my enthusiasm is
not going to be there or it's a good
representation of what we do
i politely say no what percentage of of
sellers
pay you to make the videos on their
homes um
decent amount and it really depends like
if it's an easy video to make and if
you're going to get ton of views
like i just know it's going to be
no-brainer we don't necessarily have to
get paid or like i'm worried about
getting paid but some of these videos
are just expensive to produce i mean
like
our videos are nothing cheap to produce
so then i
will put a budget together like this is
how i can do this
at a level that this property deserves
like you cannot tour a
3600 acre ranch and produce it in one
day like no chance you got to spend
three days there you got to run the
whole crew
so i put budgets together based on the
shoots where they are
sometimes people want to fly us out i'll
be like you got to cover all these and
we got to have our fee in there
and that's how it makes sense for us to
stop everything we're doing in l.a
pack all this stuff come to where you're
at shoot it and go back and edit it and
deliver it
at a timely fashion can you can you
share oh unless you have a question
oh i just wanted to talk about youtube
revenue that's what i wanted to talk
about we're on the same page
can you talk about your analytics i can
show the analytics but
in terms of revenue we're like let's see
anywhere from
uh 50 to a hundred thousand on a good
month
um consider bad revenue for youtube ad
revenue considering the views we get
which is okay wait so i was i was gonna
say
uh 90. i was going to say 80. really
where why
usually jack and i are pretty close with
it do you know how it works i'm going to
see it all right i'm gonna can i screen
record
uh yeah sure okay so you have a million
real-time views
which is incredible and it's super
consistent your
watch time man incredible watch
so i've i've i've never seen watch time
as high as yours
really one million six hundred fifty
thousand hours of watch time
the only thing i don't like man your
revenue should be
double yes and i think that's just
because you're not putting enough
mid-roll ads in the video
we don't want to we don't want to upset
the audience we're like too gentle you
know
no it's okay how many how many minerals
do you put in your videos
if it's like a 30 to 35 minute video
we'll put like four
or five maybe five minerals and then a
pre-roll post roll
yeah and you do non-skippables yeah
our cpms are not that high guys why are
they so low i don't know
i mean we garner a big international
audience you know what's crazy the
average view duration i have a feeling
it's weird the average view duration
you're getting
is the same as our second channel jack
it's under 10 minutes
for a 30 minute video but i have a
feeling it's because your videos get
recommended so much
so much people click on it watch a
miniature click off but those people
that watch
all the way through that they give you
it could be because his audience is not
very heavily based in the united states
yeah
it's like 25 percent oh you have a huge
international
oh united states yeah see ours is about
80 no it's like 80 percent i bet that
plays a big
big role india 10
india we have a big indian audience too
on the main channel a lot of people
watch from india nope yeah you know what
that's what it is it's just your
audience yeah is
only 26 i bet that 26 from the u.s
united kingdom is great but it's such a
small percentage here yeah
26 united states that's probably driving
80
of your revenue yeah it has up upside
and downside
upside like i like that our audience is
international
that gives great exposure to these
listings you know
um but downside this cpm is low but you
know we make it work
and uh we're lucky enough to be able to
cover our operations and run the team
and keep everybody happy
so you have great analytics thank you
yeah
coming from you guys you know what the
uh you know why it's so good
do you mind if i throw it it's so
consistent thank you but you know why
it's because every video is an evergreen
video that you push
yes correct every single thing you it
doesn't matter when you watch it like
with our videos
they usually die after a few days
because like nobody cares about what
happened to stock
market on a tuesday three months ago
your videos every agreement you can come
back in a few years
that's the good thing about what you're
doing you could literally walk away
today and forever
your videos would still generate
probably five
to twelve thousand dollars a month yeah
if you just decide i'm i'm done
five to twelve thousand dollars doing
nothing
i'm shocked how impressed you guys are
with the analytics it's just so
consistent and surprising
what surprised me also was that the top
search term was your name
and i figured that the top search term
would be like mansion tour but people
are searching for your name
i guess i i honestly haven't even looked
at that yeah i noticed that too
yeah yeah yeah and you're last night i
have a tough last name to you this is
absolutely
right dude yeah yeah but here's the
thing uh youtube auto recommends
so like every time i if you type in just
ns yeah it
automatically populates there was like
all right that's it yeah like if you do
en
e like we're already up there that's
awesome what was my recommendation to
you for
for the channel name because you asked
me about that i did so
i figured i told you so you were like
look your name is tough
you're like i would consider something
that's a little bit easier to remember
or like something that like
you read it and it kind of would make
sense like something like manchester un
like
you were like this isn't the ideal
scenario and mikey was kind of on the
same boat
and my thing was like and i still
believe that concept to this day
if content is good people don't care
about anything else like content has to
be good
and my thing was like my name is so odd
but i have a very simple first name
people will just like remember it like
it'll be all right and
my problem with these like mansion tours
or these things as soon as you put like
these generic names
it becomes like a almost like a tv i
wanted to be about me in a sense of like
a personality from there
we'll build the different channels like
we started ns plus
and the logic behind an s plus was like
it has just enough connotation that it
has to do with me
but it's plus it's everything else it's
the team it's the vlogs it's us storing
the rv
it's mikey being on camera it's like
featuring other people down the road so
i knew that model would work and i just
kind of stick to my guns i was like if
you want to build the name to scale
and then do businesses and uh
endorsements and that kind of stuff
it has to be on the name so i just kind
of stuck with it oh
it's worked i think i think my
recommendation would have been to to
shorten your last name yeah or do
something that would be easier to spell
that way people just have an anna
because your first name easy easy yeah
and a lot of people just call my first
name and yeah even like i'm not one of
those people
they can call it wrong like i have no
problem yeah we should talk a little bit
more about your past because i heard
yeah
what did you do before you did these
mansion tours in real estate work
um so born and raised in turkey age of
17 moved to texas
got a scholarship at texas a m um
when i moved to us couldn't speak a word
of english like i would have to grab
other turkish kids be like talk to the
teacher
this is what i need like i sucked at it
um
it's super lonely like my first two
years in u.s is like no friendships
like i sucked at the language and then
um
graduated from texas a m at the age of
22
at the time applied for green card
because i was
between the ages of 13 to 26 i was a
professional wind surfer
for 12 years seven sponsors traveled
across the country
around the world over 35 countries i was
flying
200 000 miles a year wow
another cool fact i was sponsored by
turkish airlines for seven years
for seven years straight i flew nothing
but a business class
wow everywhere around the world and i
had
200 kilos so that's like about i had 900
pounds worth of
free luggage allowance for me to carry
all my windsurfing gear around the world
i had the weirdest life that is like
that's like a dream
if you're 22 years old yeah did that get
the ladies i feel like i'm a
professional winston you know what i was
never the craziest
or like the best about ladies i was like
you would be like the ultimate bachelor
you know like the most suave sweet
talking
you know that really evolved after like
23 24 i really found my way
and i was like oh this is actually
pretty easy
uh i just have to say the right things
kind of thing i was honestly workaholic
my whole life
like when i was windsurfing i was
practicing 12 14 hours a day like
i just enjoy working i just love
improving i love progress
i'm addicted to progress it's like
progress turns me on it's like
tell me a way to make things better
let's talk like it's i'm excited about i
don't know what it is it's not even like
we need that much progress
um but windsurfing career shaped really
who i am work ethic
is such an abusive sport like i'm so
used to competing in like tough
conditions
i always tell now we wear suits shoots
home
like what are you talking i sit on a
desk all day
talk to people like this is easy like
easy
so um windsurfing really shaped who i am
got me a green card i have eb1
extraordinary ability green card
that's how i became u.s citizen in fact
i'm currently in my application
right now to like get my password like
fully become a us citizen
my dad has the same thing he's really
he's canadian yeah really
extraordinary ability yeah they call it
eb1 yeah
so you prove the us government that
whatever profession you're in
you're in the top five percent i had
three world titles in windsurfing yeah
three worlds
that means you were the best windsurfer
in the world yeah for three years
so that really shaped who i am
and age of 21 in texas right after like
the
2008 crisis i saved up quite a bit of
money
i bought myself a house and it was a
flip that
the owners couldn't finish it was like
85 done and it was like
200 000 no it was 170 000
i spent all my savings on it i was
really frugal i was kind of like you
and i bought this house i was like oh my
god i have to finish the remaining
because i have
no money left and me and my dad for 40
days straight
fixed up the house it was the greatest
40 days
of my life i was like whatever whenever
windsurfing ends
real estate is my next path and
any money i made from windsurfing i
started buying land
any off time i had i was at project
sites learning about real estate
uh talking to developers i became
addicted with it
over the course of between 2011 to 2018
i bought over
40 pieces of land in texas which i still
own to this day
i invested all my money in land and i
started getting involved with like
people's projects
uh development and the age of 26 right
at when i turned 26
i retired from wood surfing and i went
in
all in on flipping properties like i'm
talking about
construction belt on running cruise
12 to 16 hours a day hands-on building
that's where my knowledge from about
homes comes from
like i learned how to sewer line an
entire house i learned how to
run water lines and water heater from
the city tap
to water heater to distributing to
fixtures i learned how to plumb an
entire house by myself i learned i
learned how to
frame additions i can literally
genuinely
build a house from ground up i have
every skill set
wiring an entire room running panels
troubleshooting
installing fixtures roofing stainless
seam metal roofs
uh building block a laying brick i
learned it all
and that gave me such a it was such a
humbling experience like imagine
you're at age of 26 you were a
three-time world champion with surfer
sponsored by turkish airlines
making really good money for for that
kind of job how much were you
could you say i was making around like
two hundred thousand dollars a year
which is a lot
that's more and i quit that
just so like literally i had this moment
i have to tell you guys this story i
took on this like huge project this
house was
partially burned down no one wanted to
buy it i was crazy enough to be like
i'll finish this
it's one of my biggest flips i got a
plumbing bed to do
sewer line and water line it was
fourteen thousand dollars
i was like you're kidding right he's
like yeah dude this is my rate
i was like okay i know i know how to do
all this it's an insane project to
manage
i can run the cruise generally i have
about eight to twelve guys at the house
at a time
and i can on the side do this myself
over a two week period
since i know how to do it i had to do
pex lines and pvc sewer line the whole
place because it was a
old home it was all cast iron and it was
a pier and beam home so it was about two
feet above the ground
i remember this moment it's like 10 pm
at night
because i'm behind so i catch up working
late
and i'm replacing a sewer line and
literally
partial sewer was like sitting and it
like leaked all over my body
i'm like what are you doing dude like
you're you have money like you're like
but when i put my mind into something i
get so dedicated
i've still aligned the entire house
myself and it cost me 1200 in material i
saved like 12 000 bucks while running
the crew
because material cost was nothing it was
all labor that's worth it then
it was worth it but like that kind of
humbling experience so now i go into
these
houses and i talk about them it's not
like i have a full of language
i genuinely know like so that gave me
like our channel's core knowledge comes
from the fact that i ate [ __ ] for like
last
two to three years flipping homes i
flipped
i mean the amount of concrete i broke
with a jackhammer with my own hands
it's got to be over like 20 000 square
feet i'm not joking
so that three intense years of like
non-stop work and flipping homes is gave
me a huge upside and like knowledge and
understanding flips
and understanding developments so when i
came to l.a when i started touring these
homes i would meet with developers i
would make like four or five comments
they're like who are you how do you know
these things
i would come in i'll be like right in
the center of your uh living room you
have a half inch step he's like no i
don't i was like put the laser up
i was like i leveled so many homes i was
like you have a half inch dip right
there they will put a level up
it would be like half inch to three
quarters they're like holy crap
i'll be like i told you you have no idea
how many foundations i corrected in
texas
so it's weird backgrounds all
accumulated to this point with the
youtube channel
do you share that on your channel never
why not
um let's do it on the second channel
eventually we'll do it on a second
channel
like it's it's fun to talk about it when
people ask but it just
like i don't know i i'm kind of a guy
that's like
we'll just do good work and then people
will recognize it i i like
seeing loki like where did you get that
work ethic from
um i think i'm i'm i'm really
competitive
and it's not like a competitive of like
i'm gonna beat this guy
i just don't know how to stop like when
i was flipping homes
um more than half the homes i flipped
still to this day
no one has beaten those prizes like i
tell this all the time
i get appraisers call me to this day
they're like how the hell
you sold this one for this price in this
neighborhood i've
hacked the whole flipping procedure i
would go
find like really nice cabinetry stores
and buy the open boxes have it in the
inventory
when the right flip hits i would put a
thousand dollar vanity on a home that's
140 000
my homes were so standalone so good that
i broke every single neighborhood record
that i was in
and uh that just comes from the fact
that i was like i could have made money
i was like i could make
better i can put a half a million dollar
home cabinetry in a 200 000
home and i love that challenge and i
love over giving the value
same thing with these tours we can get
away with doing less but we can do more
and did people see it the best
compliment is where your work speaks for
you
so this kind of stuff it's almost like
why don't we just shut up
and do good work and we just let the
people dictate
growing up did you did your parents have
a similar work ethic or is this
something my dad is one of the hardest
working person
and uh like my dad will never complain
about anything that's what i learned
like
you know like look at my hands i have
cut after cut building the van
uh just shut up and build it yeah like i
know how to do it when am i going to
hire someone and like get a plan design
i was like okay we work a lot we're
shooting all this content to get ahead
i'm like
if i can get my assistance to help me
mikey will help me a little bit
i'll stay to like 11 or 12. we built the
van
so it's just like uh you take pride in
it and i don't know i'm just competitive
and uh i appreciate progress yeah
this van that you're building you want
to talk a little bit about oh yeah
you're stopping here on a trip yes yeah
so this has been me and mikey's goal for
a while that like we want to drive
across the country and like
shoot cool content especially now that
we have the second channel
where we can kind of shoot anything
really and then uh
mikey in fact do you want to come out
here like give your thoughts on this so
for those not aware
mikey you're the uh the voice and
the the camera behind the scenes i love
your little sometimes you'll you'll
throw in like a little comment or like
go get a close-up of it it's it's this
it's this cool little catch phrase that
that people know you
through your voice so some people may
have heard you but they have no idea
what you look like
so now it's now here you are yeah it's
weird to have people like recognize my
voice i was telling you yesterday i got
an uber a few weeks
ago and uh they were listening to a song
from our channel and i started talking
to them and they're like your voice
sounds really familiar
are you in this cameraman and i was like
this is weird
uh so um yeah it's weird sitting in
front of cameras now though
yeah yeah but coming back to the trip
question yeah
we wanted to do this across the country
trip and flying is difficult we got a
ton of camera gear and like
we have so many different skill sets i
mean we have this like 14 000
random jetboard that we wanted to use it
around the country
and then we want to shoot other stuff we
were like well we like our production to
be high
so how are we going to carry all this
stuff we were like let's rent a suburban
but
that doesn't solve it we have so much
stuff we need like a trailer too
yeah we were like maybe we take like i
was literally i have an s class i was
like maybe i sell my s-class
get it i escalated a trailer
you know because of my contractor
background i have two cars so i have my
regular business car like my
mercedes and then i have this transit
van that like i was literally running my
contracting business in texas
i brought it to la because i genuinely
didn't know what i was going to do in
l.a full of
still with my construction tools i was
like enes
stop delaying this dude this van is
probably perfect the problem is the
cargo van
it's super loud it's metal to metal um
so we spent probably
100 hours roughly first demoing the
whole thing
rebuilding the decking installing a back
seat so the rest of the team can ride
with us
putting this metal rack like a garage
shelf rack
and retrofitting it into the van sound
dampening the whole thing
uh you know covering the inside with
their phone
so it's the sick now travel production
van that we built
and we literally have all of our camera
gear we can ride up to five people
also it's it's a good starting point
because it'll get better but it's like
over time the van will improve and
improve and improve slightly right now
right now it's like stage one of the
video yeah the van's first life
you got to get something on the side of
it something is a joke it's just like i
think a plumbing company or
something like that doge logo yeah yeah
oh
my god yeah that would be cool
on our way to the moon yeah something
like that yeah
yeah um so that's the story behind it i
i think people like our friendship
between me and mikey they like that
we're not a big shot like i and i wear a
suit because i respect my job
and i i address what i'm about to say
appropriately to the house
you're towing a 50 million home you
better put a suit on that is sharp
you need to own up to that job and you
need to deliver the information in the
right way
this is not something to be joked about
so i think people respect
how we carry ourselves a lot and we get
these comments so many times
uh literally our last week's video
someone made a comment it's like
one of the most popular comments
underneath ryan sarhan's comment
we threw this home that ryan's heard
ryan comment was like i quit because
the views they've gone in two weeks
we've gone in less than one day
and we just passed by them and the
second comment was like let's talk about
something that is
unspoken these guys and ns started this
trend of like detailed walk-throughs and
everybody else pretty much copied it
yeah
like and it had like the most liked
comments so yeah just to clarify like
there was a few people out there filming
home
yeah but they're like this is a view you
know or like yeah
this is a 100 million dollar home and
it's like two like here we have shots
it's like eight minute video of uh
like this is where the kids you know
what's interesting is more about him and
his personality yeah
less about the house producer michael i
feel like it's more about what he's
gonna say and what he's wearing
uh in his watch than it is about the
house it has more of a backdrop
when you watch more from michael with
yours you really focus on the property
and by doing that we actually have more
personality in my opinion
because we set ourselves so distinctly
apart yeah
and kind of goes back to like good luck
copying it
i i genuinely look forward to someone
tackling a chat
a challenge as big as what we tackle on
a weekly basis and try
to truly compete with us at both on
knowledge and production
uh i've been a three-time world champion
when server i attack a lot of big
challenges
this is without a doubt one of the most
difficult things
we've ever had to work around and like
truly run it and figure out a way to do
it efficiently
it's refreshing to hear you jack like
how you get it
right like being around graham or being
able to work with him
and learn and observe and do stuff
around graham
would be opportunity of a lifetime i'll
do it in a heartbeat and
you know when we're hiring i'm like i
would kill to be around people like me
people like mikey um i want to tell this
story
how i got into la which is really
interesting i think you will get a
really good kick out of it so
i started flipping homes in texas quit
being a windsurfer and
anytime i could see like three four days
of like opening where i could take a
vacation
i was obsessed with million dollar
listing i watched every episode this is
not a joke
more than 20 30 times like i'm not
joking
and i was just obsessed with la i don't
know what it is it's like the
architecture the fanciness you know
million dollar
listing made it look really good
glamorized now that i'm in it oh my god
it's totally the opposite um it's like
it's almost funny i remember you were
kind of heartbroken when you realized
how fake that show was real
heartbroken is understating yeah i
thought the two agents would really
meet each other in the car off of the
freeway side by side
negotiating back and forth rolling down
the window i thought that's what it was
like
yeah throwing offers now you see these
mean emails you're like we need a
response by 12 p.m
um anyway so i would come to l.a not
only
not knowing a single person i'll just
drive around look properties
i would just hope for a glimpse of like
inspiration or like something that i'm
like
that's my end right so my third time
coming to like literally coming in just
like driving around i didn't even have
friends here
i was following literally everyone a
million dollar listing and like anybody
that i
saw on the show or a big list agent in
la
and i was following sam real and i know
you know sam right
i booked a ticket three months in
advance to go to la
and it was the night i was packing the
next day i was gonna leave to la
and send me the post on instagram he's
like i'm gonna pick
two of you guys to come and shout out of
me for a day all you have to do is
follow me you know like leave the
comment and share my post something like
that like something random
where he was trying to grow his audience
i was like wow
what an opportunity i was like i would
kill to hang out with this guy
then of course i've like made the
comment and shared and all that and like
within an hour he had like 150 people
i was like i'm not going to win this i
was like what can i do
to win this i was obsessed i was like
this opportunity is
killer and i really want to give sam
credit for this because
sam is the reason i made my move to la
quicker than i normally would have
um so i was like i grabbed my camera
last minute
i landed in l.a i landed until around
like 3 a.m the next morning
i slept like two hours i went up the
hollywood hills put my tripod
set the camera i had like a really nice
view not knowingly i had two of sam's
listings
right behind me on that backdrop i
didn't even knew it
it's two upcoming listings and i shot a
bunch of takes on like who i am
what i do why he should chose me how
much like this
really means to me i went down to
beverly hills edited it all day
and i made him a 10-minute reel of who i
am why he should chose me
and i was like i was like i'm just gonna
drop it off at nessicur's
i went there i'm like what if he doesn't
see it like this would kill me i spent
i was there for like three days i burned
my first full day
trying to make this video i was like i'm
just gonna dress nice and go there be
like i'm a client i want to talk to
samurail
so i went over there like i'm like can i
talk to sam they're like
wait a minute and his assistant at the
time uh
uh came down which i'm really good
friends with now
and he's like hey man what's up how can
i help you i'm like dude this is
embarrassing
i really wanted to win this um
giveaway and i made this video i'm so
afraid he may not see it
uh but now that i know you're having it
can you show it to him like i really
want to win this he goes
you made a video for that instagram post
he's like
i made that post as a like fine like
will grove said
you made a full video i'm like yeah like
i spent the whole day on it it's really
good like please make sure sam sees that
he goes
no no no he's like sam is coming in an
hour you want to pitch it in person
so hour later i'm in the office with sam
and uh sam is like you made like he
curses a lot in a good way
he's like you made a video i'm like dude
this would mean a lot that like i'm
trying to like figure out my way to l.a
he's like you're nuts he watched the
video he couldn't stop smiling the whole
time he goes
he goes what are you doing tonight i was
like i don't and you know what i have
such
gut instincts i brought a suit with me i
was like i'm gonna make this work
like this is gonna work i knew it i
brought a suit with me he goes
million dollar listing season eight
premier party is tonight you want to
meet the whole cast
he's like i'm gonna take you that very
night i met sam sam took me a million
dollar listing los angeles party i met
josh
i made everybody i'm like oh my god
how did this happen in the last 24 hours
this is insane
right there i was like this is the city
you need to be in your craziness
works here you can it does like it works
these like ideas of like almost of like
you're ridiculous
actually works in l.a after hanging out
that night i was like i couldn't believe
the whole night i was so happy i have a
photo with sam
if you go to my instagram you can pull
the photo uh
and then sam was like he's like screw
shadowing me for a day he goes what are
you doing in december he's like why
don't i give you a desk here
i went back home texas i worked non-stop
for like 50 days
finished two of my flips i came to l.a
in december this is like three years ago
and i spent two full weeks helping sam
out running
errands with him for free and it was the
greatest two weeks i've ever spent
and at that point it clicked me i was
like if these are if these agents can
make it in la
i'll figure it out i went back to la i
went back to
texas five months i sold my home i
finished the other couple projects i had
i done like 15 garage sales i liquidated
my whole life and what i built in texas
in the last nine years i packed my van
to the grim
with my construction tools my desk and
my tv
i shipped my messages and then literally
mikey helped me
packing that van like not a joke like he
was the last person i saw
packing the van and i moved to la
and that's the story so
yeah i wanted to say this because like
partially i'm bummed out with a new
generation and like
how little initiative they take it's
kind of refreshing to hear
jack and how he understands the
opportunity and sees it
and respects it but did you do sam's
laundry
i have not done sam's laundry without a
heartbeat without a doubt in a heartbeat
it's it's not but here's the thing do
you do great laundry
no but i would have okay cool here's the
thing um
that's unspoken i mean you don't have to
be told to do sam's laundry
you would have just done it and i think
that's a quality that you can't ask of
somebody
it's just it's already there yeah so
that that
jack and i made the mistake of saying
like we want these qualities in somebody
to be willing to do this
and everyone said i can't believe you
would you would assume that i would do
lot
but but that's that's the sort of stuff
you can't describe graham was
referencing when we were going through
the hiring so yeah
so enos for the channel like i need an
assistant editor
yeah we saw your we saw your video and
how you found
um alex alex and we were like this is
great let's do this exact same thing you
know so even in the video we're like
we're copying graham
yeah we we like say that um we filmed
the whole thing we like
we like do it in one take all our
requirements we like wrote down bullet
points you know
what we're paying all this stuff we were
inspired by you guys yeah
and and uh it's we're starting to get
the submissions now but it really didn't
work out as well as did for you
number one i think because our channel
is not as personality based it's more
about the houses people don't know us
that well
yeah we don't have as big of a core
audience you know and it was a smaller
position it's basically we were looking
for a paid intern really yeah maybe we
had a bad way of articulating it we
we didn't articulate it well enough and
we really got destroyed on how much we
were paying
you know it's like how much are you
paying 15. 15 an hour but we're looking
for like an 18 19 year old kid who lives
with his parents who like wants to learn
how to edit something right you can't
describe that
that's what jack and i learned you can't
describe we were we were saying like
you got to be willing to like do laundry
pick up bailey's poop
it's like yeah and jack was like it's
not going to be glamorous by any means
graham i again disagree with you i
thought it was smart and i'm like
you know why because you guys need that
person that has care
you guys are a lean and mean team and
that person cannot be like okay i'm
gonna come in and put 50 hours
no like you guys needed that edge yes
you guys might have gone
bash on the comments but realistically
that's the person you guys are looking
for you guys were just
brutally honest and if they have a
problem
i mean this is such an amazing group of
team of people to be around
you guys are literally moving and
shaking things you'll get some great
submissions though i watched like 15-20
yeah yeah
we we recommend that if by the way if
you're watching this if you're looking
to hire anybody
type in graham stefan interview go down
the list of people who uh
and and poach those people because i
want to say we had five
or something that's good got some good
support that we wanted to hire
it's just we could i mean obviously we
could only pick one and there are so
many other variables of just like
we would feel bad if you quit like there
were people making like six figures who
were willing to quit their job and move
across the country
to do jack's laundry pick up basically
and whereas like we would feel
bad if that didn't work out because
that's too big of a risk
or you know moving a big family across
the country it's like stuff like that it
was
it was tough it was time but there are
people in there in that list
who like in the future we're going to go
back through that list
and i think we're going to yeah we're
going to pick more people yeah
another thing we're working on we're
partnered up with two companies so far
one of them is tophab
it's a real estate database uh analytics
platform basically
you know how we in real estate look at
like 20 different websites to gather all
the information
yeah it's a one website gathers all that
information puts it into a beautiful
interface
you can look at how loud a neighborhood
is or like how many people in your
neighborhood has a pool
and when they pull their permit to
getting ai to
give you a calculated um comparables
price per square foot tax analysis so
many other aspects
a mind-blowing amount of data points
mind-blowing and their point was like
let's say
you want to invest in a certain part of
california without leaving your home
in an hour or two looking at the right
databases you should be able to educate
yourself as good as a
realtor who works in that field and then
you can simply go back
and then make your decisions accordingly
it's a really efficient
kind of like an investing in uh database
platform in regards to real estate and
the second company we're working with is
picasso
so that's a really unique concept a lot
of people associate that with timeshare
but
they go and they buy the property they
stage the whole thing they fix
anything that needs to be done and then
from there they set up the management
llc on it
uh put the property manager maintenance
and all that stuff and they divide it to
one-fourth or one-eighth
of ownerships so you say you buy to
one-fourth
quarter of the time over a year you own
uh the staying
rights in the property they have a
beautiful app that you go in
you type in the dates you want like a
hotel they booked a place for you
everything is ready when you come in
and you own one fourth of the home so as
the property
i appreciate you get the upside on that
they can finance it for you
they handle all the transactions you can
use a realtor of your choice to sell it
and they were just evaluated at one
billion dollars
the fastest awesome to get to a billion
right yeah one of the fastest companies
to get to a billion dollar evaluation
uh co-founders of dot loop and zillow is
back in the company
um so it's a pretty exciting project for
us
it's us and the altman brothers that are
kind of like the brand
uh partners brand ambassadors for the
company so that's very cool
congratulations thank you thank you
we're really excited about it
cool well thank you guys so much both
for coming here this has been a really
fun episode i've been really happy with
hearing some of your stories i had no
idea from some of this so it's really
cool hearing this from you thank you
guys so much for having us thank you for
having us i can't imagine uh
when we jumped on that open house when
you were there it was years ago that we
would be on your podcast two years from
now yeah
pretty crazy a lot could happen in uh
what two years two years
be sure to watch watch graham's youtube
course yeah oh yes and that's right
two hundred dollars off for the next
seven days and then and then it's done
that's it
as well mentorship group and subscribe
to the channel
and smash like button bye
step it up jesus we're good
yeah i'm probably moving it right i'm so
used to moving in the videos